[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui le rapprochement
historique entre israël et deux pays
arabes du golfe les émirats arabes unis
et le bahreïn suscitant autant d'espoir
pour les uns que d'inquiétude pour les
autres le nouveau partenariat à risque
de bouleverser en profondeur le paysage
géopolitique de la région
quels sont donc les changements qui ont
fait trembler la région récemment le 15
septembre
les émirats et le bar est ici les
accords de normalisation avec israël à
la maison blanche reconnaissance
mutuelle coopération économique et
défense le développement des relations
bilatérales va connaître un nouvel élan
l'egypte et oman félicite cet accord
mais la plupart des états arabes du
golfe adopte une position attentiste
de leur côté la turquie et l'iran sont
outrés par ce deal qu'il considère comme
une trahison des intérêts des
palestiniens l'état palestinien quant à
lui perd peu un peu le soutien des pays
arabes après avoir échoué à convaincre
la ligue arabe de condamner l'entente la
palestine quitte la présidence de
l'organisation
en signe de solidarité une vague de
manifestations se propage dans le monde
musulman
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il faut
savoir sur le statut international
actuel de l'état d'israël c'est le blitz
créée en 1948 israël est reconnue
aujourd'hui par cent soixante trois
états membres de l'onu sur 193 au total
parmi ceux qui ne le reconnaissent pas
et figures principalement des pays
musulmans est pratiquement tous les
états arabes
cependant on peut désormais enlevé
quatre pays à cette liste l'égypte la
jordanie les émirats arabes unis et
bahreïn
le premier état arabe à normaliser ses
relations avec israël et l'egypte sous
l'égide des états unis l'accord de paix
signé en 1979 selon ses termes le caire
reconnaît l'état hébreu et permet aux
navires israéliens d'emprunter le canal
de suez un échange ils récupèrent le
sinaï conquis en 1967 par israël suite à
la guerre de six jours
quinze ans plus tard toujours sous
l'égide de washington lé premier
ministre israélien itzhak rabin et
jordanien abdel salam majali signent un
traité de paix l'une des raisons qui
poussent la jordanie et à faire ce pas
est la promesse d'une aide financière et
diplomatique des états unis à un moment
où le pays traverse une crise sans
précédent
une nouvelle ère commence dans les
relations entre israël et le monde arabe
le 15 septembre
les émirats arabes unis et le bahreïn si
chacun des accords de paix avec israël
appelez les accords d'abraham en plus
d'une reconnaissance mutuelle les
signataires s'engagent à coopérer dans
pratiquement tous les domaines allant de
la défense et l'économie jusqu'aux
tourisme et la santé au niveau régional
ce rapprochement inédit suscite des
réactions contrastées l'egypte et oman
se disent favorables odile tandis que la
turquie et l'iran s'y opposent fermement
ankara va jusqu'à menacer de rompre les
relations diplomatiques avec abu dhabi
téhéran se sont aussi obligés de réagir
car il voit dans ce nouveau partenariat
une menace pour son influence dans la
région
ce rapprochement risque aussi d'avoir un
fort impact sur le conflit israélo
palestinien
car la solidarité des pays arabes face à
la question palestinienne
se fissure de plus en plus la preuve la
ligue arabe refuse de condamner la
décision des émirats est de barrer et
pourtant la délégation palestinienne en
avait fait la demande expresse donald
trump de son côté se veut confiant pour
lui ce n'est qu'un début et d'autres
pays arabes vont bientôt se joindre aux
accords d'abraham
peut-on vraiment parler de la fin du
dialogue israélo-palestinien dans le
nouveau contexte de rapprochement entre
israël et les deux états arabes
comment abu dhabi et manama
explique-t-il leur décision de s'ouvrir
à israël
quels avantages politiques et
économiques ce nouvel accord promet-il à
ses signataires pour répondre à ces
questions nous rejoignons karim sader
politologue et professeur à l'université
saint joseph de beyrouth
monsieur sader bonjour bonjour tout
d'abord première question pourquoi ce
rapprochement at il lieu maintenant
seulement un an après le deal du siècle
et qualifié d' injuste par la majeure
partie de la communauté internationale
nous sommes comme vous le savez à la fin
du mandat de demain preuve en campagne
pour sa réélection et ce dernier avait
pris l'engagement de cela 2 d'amorcer un
accord entre israéliens et palestiniens
c'est un petit peu le le challenge que
veut relever tout président américain or
il s'avère que ce deal du siècle comme
il a été appelé est loin de faire
l'unanimité
le moins qu'on puisse dire il a été
assez massivement rejetée donc dans
notre homme devait compenser quelque
part la fin de son mandat et sa
politique arabe par justement ce
rapprochement donc en quelque sorte
c'est l'échec du plan du deal du siècle
entre guillemets qui a accéléré ce
rapprochement donc entre déjà les
émirats arabes unis par dell d'un côté
et israël
d'autant plus que les la réélection de
notre temps loin d'être acquis 1 on ne
vend rien l'état qui pour l'instant pour
lui donc il fallait aussi accéléré dans
le calendrier mais
dix du siècle porté essentiellement sur
la question palestinienne alors pourquoi
parmi les autres pays arabes
aujourd'hui ce sont le bahreïn et les
émirats arabes unis qui décident de
normaliser les relations avec israël
c'est un rapprochement tactique on est
pas dans un processus de paix ce n'est
pas la symbolique présence de sadate à
la knesset en 79
ce n'est pas à la poignée de main d'où
ce nom là on est dans un rapprochement
purement géopolitique purement tact ce
rapprochement il est le fruit d'une
alliance qui est un secret de
polichinelle depuis le départ celle qui
lie l'administration preuve les d'israël
et certains monarques des pays du globe
avec en tête
ahmad behzad le prince héritier d'abou
dhabi les émirats arabes unis à badens
salman le prince héritier saoudien
donc ce qui lie c'est ces acteurs-là
depuis le départ c'est l'animosité
envers l'iran entre autres donc ce
rapprochement quelque part il vient
comme un premier pas un premier pas
l'officialisation de ces relations que
souhaiterait avoir la kz abou dhabi ryad
d'à côté et un tel aviv de l'autre donc
il fallait que quelqu'un fasse ce
premier pas
ce premier pas a été fait par les
émirats arabes unis et bahreïn ce n'est
pas un hasard
à laudun c'est régine là si vous voulez
aussi non pas le problème de leur
opinion ce sont certes des
pétromonarchies ouverte à la
globalisation économique
mais ce sont des monarchies aussi
autoritaristes et leurs espaces
politiques et leurs opinions publiques
sont inexistantes
donc voilà c'est ça a été beaucoup plus
facile ou baleines et les émirats arabes
unis de franchir ce pas c'est le sera
beaucoup moins pour les zélés pardon
pour l'arabie saoudite
or parler j'imagine qui elle devra
justement préparer le terrain c'est en
quelque sorte en éclaireur que les
émirats rivard et se sont dirigés vers
ce cette normalisation monsieur sader
merci beaucoup
tout de suite nous allons poursuivre
notre analyse mai
nous vous retrouverons en fin d'émission
pour plus de détails sur la question
merci encore un tournant historique dans
les relations israélo arabe
le 15 septembre sous l'égide des états
unis israël les émirats arabes unis et
le bahreïn signent les accords d'abrams
une appellation qui fait référence au
personnage biblique abraham considéré
comme le père des trois religions
la cérémonie en grande pompe se déroule
sur la pelouse de la maison blanche
devant plusieurs centaines de personnes
le texte est composé de trois documents
une déclaration trilatérale qui sert de
préambule commun une déclaration de paix
entre israël et le bahreïn est un traité
de paix à proprement parler entre israël
et les émirats arabes unis le premier à
être annoncé et l accord israël aux
émirats qu'il décrit en détail le
processus de réconciliation entre les
deux états sa clause centrale c'est
l'établissement de relations
diplomatiques et un échange
d'ambassadeurs
ce qui fait des miracles le troisième
pays arabe avec lequel israël entretient
des relations diplomatiques le traité
stipule en outre que les deux états
établiront des accords bilatéraux de
coopération dans de nombreux domaines
finance investissement santé sciences
technologies et énergies
impensable il ya seulement quelques mois
ce rapprochement a pourtant bien eu lieu
quels sont les événements qui ont permis
ce processus au début de l'été
l'ambassadeur des émirats à washington
youssef al otaïba publié dans un journal
israélien
un texte dans lequel il évoque l'énorme
potentiel de la coopération israélo et
mérienne cependant à condition que
tel-aviv abandonne son projet d'annexion
de la cisjordanie
en effet début juillet le premier
ministre israélien benjamin netanyahu
elle réitère à plusieurs reprises sa
volonté de lancer l'annexion de
territoires à l'ouest du fleuve jourdain
en conformité avec le plan du siècle de
donald trump
pourtant à la date prévue l'annexion ne
se produit pas le signal est vite capté
abu dhabi mais surtout à washington les
états unis profitent de l'occasion pour
démarrer les pourparlers entre tel-aviv
et abu dhabi résultats le 13 août les
deux états annonçant futur accord de
normalisation mais avec une pré
condition avancée par les émirats arabes
unis la suspension de l'annexion de la
cisjordanie
une mesure qui sera elle considère
pourtant comme temporaire mais est la
presse arabe quand elle cite un autre
facteur important qui aurait poussé à
abou dhabi à conclure la paix avec
tel-aviv
c'est l'iran que les deux états
considèrent comme une menace
pourtant si les émirats et israël évite
de reconnaître le lien entre l'accord et
la menace iranienne
bahreïn lui ne le cache pas l'iran a
choisi de se comporter de plusieurs
manières en dominateur et est devenu un
danger permanent qui nuit à notre
sécurité intérieure
il n'est pas sage de voir la menace est
d'attendre qu'elle nous atteignent si
nous pouvons l'éviter de quelques
manières que ce soit pourtant l'accord
de paix entre bahreïn et israël ne fait
pas mention explicite d'une menace
iranienne
tout comme le traité israël au émirati
d'ailleurs il établi les relations
diplomatiques entre les deux états et
crée le fondement d'une coopération
mutuelle dans une série de domaines
commerce et que été tourisme santé et
autres avancées stratégiques pour le
bahreïn cet accord représente aussi une
belle victoire pour le premier ministre
israélien qui ne cache pas sa
satisfaction
il nous a fallu 26 ans entre le deuxième
accord de paix avec un pays arabe et le
troisième mais seulement 29 jours entre
le 3e et le 4e et lille y en aura
d'autres les bénéfices politiques sont
aussi nombreux pour le principal
médiateur de ces accords donald trump en
pleine campagne électorale le président
américain profite de l'occasion pour
améliorer son bilan diplomatique
nous sommes ici cet après-midi pour
changer le cours de l'histoire
après des décennies de division et de
conflits nous marquons l'aube d'un
nouveau moyen-orient
soucieux de son image de faiseur de paix
le président américain met en avant son
rôle de médiateur
non sans un effet positif sur sa
popularité évidemment selon un récent
sondage yougov le taux d'approbation du
président américain a grimpé de 40 à 40
% en un mois
quelle est la réaction du reste du monde
musulman aux accords entre israël les
émirats arabes unis et le bahreïn
peuvent-ils avoir un impact sur le
dialogue israélo palestinien
que fera l'iran la réponse après la
pause
[Musique]
un bouleversement dans le jeu
géopolitique au moyen-orient
les émirats arabes unis et le bahreïn
deviennent les premiers états arabes du
golfe à nous est presque simultanément
des relations avec l'état hébreu
une percée historique qui ouvre une
nouvelle page dans l'histoire
tumultueuse des relations israélo arabe
les relations entre israël et les pays
arabes étaient pourtant partie du
mauvais pied suite à l'adoption du plan
de partage de la palestine par l'onu
israël proclame son indépendance le 14
mai 1948
le lendemain les pays arabes voisins
déclare la guerre au nouvel état
résultat l'armée israélienne écrase les
forces arabes inexpérimentés et diviser
les territoires palestiniens sont soit
annexé par israël soient rattachés à la
jordanie et à l'egypte
cette situation donne lieu à des
tensions transfrontalières mutuelle qui
se poursuivre au cours des années
suivantes
déterminé à y mettre fin en 1956 israël
profite de la campagne de suez engagé
par les troupes franco britanniques pour
lancer une offensive militaire contre
l'egypte pourtant la tacc d'israël et
fermement condamnée par les nations
unies
sous pression internationale israël
quitte gaza et le sinaï en mars 1957 un
tournant majeur dans l'histoire israélo
arabe se produit avec la guerre des six
jours
en imposant en 1967 la fermeture du
détroit de tiran l'egypte bloquent la
voie d'accès au port israélien d'eilat
le chef d'état major israélien le
général
itzhak rabin propose de riposter par une
offensive militaire
le premier ministre levi eshkol se
laisse convaincre supériorité militaire
finesse stratégique
qualité du renseignement technique et
humain tous ces facteurs expliquent
pourquoi seulement quelques jours ont
suffi à l'armée israélienne pour défaire
son ennemi le sinaï
la cisjordanie jérusalem est et la bande
de gaza et le plateau du golan sont
conquis appuyé par la syrie l'egypte et
c'est en 1973 de laver l'affront de la
guerre des six-jours et de récupérer le
sinaï le début de l'offensive et
favorables à l'egypte et à la syrie mais
israël et d militairement par les états
unis reprend bientôt davantage c'est
l'échec l'approchent militaires ayant
échoué l'egypte se tournent désormais
vers la diplomatie en novembre 1977 le
président égyptien annonce sa volonté de
se rendre à jérusalem pour entreprendre
des négociations avec les israéliens
s'ensuit la première visite d'un chef de
l'état arabe en israël et les
négociations à camp david qui
aboutissent à un accord de paix le
président égyptien récupère le sinaï en
échange d'une reconnaissance d'israël
l'acte lui vaut de farouches critiques
de la part des pays arabes qui exclut
l'egypte de la ligue arabe pour dix ans
dans cette confrontation israélo arabe
l'intervention israélienne au liban en
1982 jette de l'huile sur le feu
l'objectif est de mettre fin aux
attaques que l'ol paie entreprend depuis
le territoire libanais résultat les
infrastructures palestiniennes sont
détruites
la situation évolue en 1988 lorsque l'ol
paie accepte en principe la négociation
avec israël
les deux parties commencent à mener des
négociations secrètes sous médiation des
etats-unis
le processus abouti à la signature des
accords à oslo en 1993
pour la première fois israël reconnaît
l'ol paie comme représentante du peuple
palestinien dans la même lancée la
jordanie accepte aussi de signer un
accord de paix avec israël l'année
suivante sa motivation
la promesse des états unis d'effacer une
dette de plus de 700 millions de dollars
à cela s'ajoute une aide diplomatique
que washington a promis au royaume
ce soutien affiché provoque de vives
réactions du monde arabe mais elles se
limiteront à quelques déclarations
virulentes
paradoxalement c'est dans les années
2000 que la palestine commence à perdre
peu à peu le soutien du monde arabe
d'abord parce que celui-ci se
consolident progressivement face à un
autre poids lourd régional qui monte en
puissance et fait miroiter son programme
nucléaire l'iran
l'autre facteur est le renforcement de
la coopération économique et militaire
avec les états unis par israël et par
les pays arabes du golfe en 2017 une
réunion secrète au plus haut niveau
aurait même eu lieu entre netanyahu et
le prince saoudien mohammed bin salman
autre preuve la réaction plutôt positive
de la part d'un certain nombre de pays
arabes dont l'arabie saoudite les
émirats arabes unis le bahreïn et oman
lors du plan du siècle de donald trump
alors qu'une autre partie des états
arabes
ils sont farouchement opposés les
palestiniens sont pris de court par le
tournant israéliens de leurs alliés
arabes
outre l autorité palestinienne rappel
c'est ambassadeur à bahreïn et aux
émirats exige des deux pays de revenir
sur leur décision
ce projet récemment dévoilé et en coup
de poignard dans le dos et nous le
rejetons catégoriquement
cependant au niveau diplomatique les
pays de la région n'affiche que très peu
de solidarité avec la position
palestinienne
en effet deux états musulmans seulement
ont explicitement critiqué les accords
c'est tout d'abord l'iran qui s'oppose à
la percée diplomatique de son ennemi
juré israël
téhéran accuse le bahreïn d'être je cite
complices des crimes israéliens et va
jusqu'à menacer les émirats
militairement
l'autre voix critiques et celle de la
turquie fidèles championne de la cause
palestinienne
ankara dénonce une trahison des émirats
menace abou dhabi de sanctions est même
de rupture de liens diplomatiques ferme
mais solitaire ces deux voies ne
parviennent pas à changer le tableau
général les accords de paix avec israël
sont accueillis par les capitales
musulmane avec une retenue plutôt
inhabituel du côté du liban et de la
jordanie
on n'affiche aucune condamnation des
progrès isralien la position officielle
consiste en une prudence face aux
promesses israélienne mais un soutien
affiché à l effort de la paix oman et
l'egypte vont même plus loin et se
félicite de la normalisation entre les
deux pays arabes et tel aviv
quant aux autres pays islamiques il
préfère garder le silence et ne commente
pas directement les accords tout en
assurant toujours soutenir la cause
palestinienne
la grande absente de ces réactions
l'arabie saoudite garde aussi une
certaine neutralité et pourtant selon
les médias arabes
la normalisation n'aurait pas pu avoir
lieu sans l'aval de ryad
d'après le wall street journal la
famille royale saoudienne seraient
divisés sur l'avenir de ses liens avec
israël selon le journal le roi salman
campe sur une position ferme face à
tel-aviv mais son fils le prince
héritier mohammed bin salman serait
ouvert à une normalisation avec l'état
hébreu et aux opportunités commerciales
qui pourraient s'ouvrir
toujours d'après le wall street journal
il aurait été au courant de la
préparation de l'accord entre tel-aviv
et
d'avis mais n'en a pas parlé à son père
de peur qu'il ne sabotent la
réconciliation quoi qu'il en soit ryad
et mais une déclaration sans équivoque
le pays affirme rester attachés aux
principes de l'initiative de paix arabe
des principes que les émirats et le
bahreïn viennent dé facto d'enfreindre
en théorie les pays arabes se sont
entendus pour ne pas reconnaître
officiellement l'état d'israël avant
qu'ils ne remplissent deux conditions
premièrement israël doit conclure la
paix avec la palestine
deuxièmement l'état judaïque doit
quitter tous les territoires occupés et
revenir aux frontières de 1967
tels sont les termes de l'initiative de
paix arabe une feuille de route adoptée
par la ligue arabe en 2002 est toujours
en vigueur
cependant les émirats et le bahreïn
décide soudainement de faire cavalier
seul
une mutation profonde du rapport de
forces au moyen-orient qui est
maintenant confirmée par la ligue arabe
ainsi le 9 septembre le sommet arabe
rejettent une résolution palestinienne
condamnant la normalisation entre
tel-aviv et abu dhabi
seul le yémen et la somalie ont approuvé
l'initiative sur une vingtaine de pays
membres lâché par ses alliés l'autorité
palestinienne s'insurge du manque de
discipline de la ligue et en riposte
elle quitte sa présidence de la ligue
arabe appelle commencé il n'y a aucun
honneur à voir les arabes se précipiter
vers une normalisation
y at il une chance de voir d'autres
états musulmans suivre la voie tracée
par les émirats et bien la réponse est
oui selon donald trump à la mi septembre
il annoncé que cinq ou six pays était
prêt à conclure à leur tour des traités
avec israël vers la fin du mois le
nombre qu'il cite montrent un oeuf
trompent affirme que même l'arabie
saoudite et réfléchi mais le fera au bon
moment
le premier ministre israélien benjamin
netanyahu dévoile son jeu et confirme
son pays
une bien des négociations avec plusieurs
états arabes et musulmans concrètement
oman le qatar et le maroc sont cités par
les médias israéliens les deux derniers
n'y est pourtant à voir ses intentions
enfin donald trump a révélé récemment l'
enthousiasme du koweït pour une
réconciliation avec tel aviv
j'ai reçu deux appels ce matin de pays
qui veulent savoir quand ils pourront
participer à l'accord ce n'est pas comme
si nous leur donnions quoi que ce soit
mais ils veulent la sécurité ils veulent
la paix ils sont vraiment fatiguées de
se battre
le front commun musulmans pro
palestiniens et entier israël est
désormais rompu
cela dit quelle configuration est en
mesure de le remplacer
l'autorité palestinienne s'alarment déjà
du fait que le rapprochement arabo
israélien ne se ferait pas au nom de la
paix mais pour s'unir face à un ennemi
commun
l'iran cette hypothèse est en partie
confirmé début septembre par le
secrétaire d'état américain mike pompéo
qui propose aux émirats et israël de
joindre leurs forces contre terre les
émirats arabes unis et israël
reconnaisse tous deux que dire en
présente une grave menace
et maintenant qu'ils ont trouvé la voie
pour nouer des relations ces dernières
peuvent aboutir à la création d'une
coalition pour garantir que cette menace
n'atteignent jamais les côtes
américaines et ne nuise à personne au
moyen-orient cela fait d'ailleurs un an
que washington s'efforce de construire
une coalition régionale anti iranienne
l'idée a été dévoilée par mike pompéo en
septembre 2019 mais n'incluaient pas
israël à l'époque maintenant que
tel-aviv n'est plus isolé le succès de
la campagne de pressions américaines sur
l'iran et il assuré à quels changements
peut-on encore s'attendre sur
l'échiquier politique du moyen-orient
pour mieux comprendre toutes les
transformations qui se perd dans la
région nous revenons vers karim sader
politologue et professeur à l'université
saint joseph de beyrouth
monsieur sader donald trump dit que cinq
ou six autres pays sont prêts à
normaliser les relations avec israël
pensez vous que c'est vraiment le cas et
si oui quelles sont ces pays je pense
que autour de l'art
samedi d' autres pétromonarchies devrait
franchir le pas j'imagine que oman
pourrait suivre de par sa politique de
neutralité en quelque sorte de par le
fait qu'elle n'a jamais eu vraiment un
discours hostiles à israël il faut quand
même avoir l'esprit que romane et le
qatar ont été les premiers
pétromonarchies des premières
pétromonarchies avoir ouvert des liens
diplomatiques et commerciales et
commerciaux avec avec des pâtes israël
donc il n'est pas exclu que romain ne
soit le prochain sur la liste
je peux pas faire le qu'un pays par pays
mais je pense que de nombreuses autres
monarchies
il faut avoir à l'esprit quelque part
que là on est dans le club des
monarchies arabes
celles qui ont eu peur des printemps
arabes et celle pour qui un
rapprochement avec ce fait elle n'est
pas un tabou
je ne vois pas d'obstacle à ce que le
maroc s'éloigner un peu de la vers le
maghreb ne voit pas d'obstacle à ce que
le maroc également si normaliser ses
relations avec je crois que c'est une
quelque chose qui va une tendance qui va
être amené à être sur yves montand
différentes relances d'euros différentes
raisons qui sont d'ordre géopolitique et
géostratégique aujourd'hui l'échiquier
énormément changé et la cause
palestinienne qui était en quelque sorte
le tabou avant qui empêchait tout
rapprochement est aujourd'hui n'a pas la
même portée selon vous et quelle est la
cause du dégel entre les pays arabes et
israël je veux dire la vraie cause la
cause principale est ce que c'est l'iran
où il ya d'autres raisons peut-être
moins visibles aujourd'hui sur
l'échiquier mondial
évidemment que le premier facteur de
rapprochement c'est cette animosité
envers l'iran forcément
mais il n'est pas le seul on a
longuement parlé j'aimerais quand même
parler d'autres éléments qui cimente ce
rapprochement
il ya là de la turquie l'animosité la
rivalité en faire la queue n'oublions
pas que les pétromonarchies suis dit
alors je mets le qatar entre parenthèses
peut-être pas le temps d'en parler
maintenant
mais le catalan est aujourd'hui en
quarantaine par ses voisins il est
proche de la turquie et soutient les
frères musulmans mais à l'exception de
se tenir à point les pétromonarchies du
golfe arabie saoudite émirats en tête
ont une animosité une forte hostilité
envers
iran mais également aux pères des frères
musulmans qui le deuxième ennemi juré or
aujourd'hui de soutien lui permet
aisément à part le qatar c'est la
turquie la turquie qui en plus a sur
activisme en méditerranée on l'a vu ces
dernières semaines ces derniers mois et
les ambitions de terre daugan inquiète
énormément les pays du golfe dont qui
veulent avoir un relais en méditerranée
soit d autre que la turquie
et j'ajoute enfin un facteur très
important c'est que les pays du golfe
ont vu constatée ces dernières années
que le grand parrain leurs alliés
américains celui sur lequel repose toute
leur sécurité
cette alliance a des failles à des
nombreuses failles
on l'a vu la quête d'indépendance des
états unis
d'un point de vue énergétique a rendu
caduque en quelque sorte ce partenariat
historique entre ryad et washington
pétrole contre sécurité donc quelque
part aphone et les pays du golfe
cherchent des actes d alliance internet
et quoique mieux que dit que l'état
d'israël et préparent pour leur garantir
un une rune face aux deux autres
puissances en a rappelé son accueil qui
est l'iran une alliance d'autant plus
qu'une rapprochement avec stress est un
gage encore plus solide une caution pour
garder le soutien du parrain américain
monsieur sader merci beaucoup pour votre
analyse je rappelle karim sader
politologue et professeur à l'université
saint joseph de beyrouth était
aujourd'hui avec nous cette partie là
n'est pas encore terminée la semaine
prochaine une nouvelle partie vous
attend avec d'autres pions sur
l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]